you mentioned in one of your lectures on
virology that there are more viruses in
a liter of coastal seawater than people
on earth
in the
nature article titled microbiology by
numbers it says there are 10 to the 31
viruses on earth
also it says that the rate of viral
infection in the ocean stands at
10 to the 23 infections per second
and these infections remove 20 to 40
percent
of all bacterial cells each day there's
a war going on
do you uh what do you make of these
numbers oh
why are there so many viruses so the the
numbers you're quoting they're in my
first
virology lecture right because
people don't know these numbers and they
get wow they get wowed by them and so i
love to give them
so they decide to interrupt as i was
saying uh offline you have one of the
best introductory lectures on virology
that i've ever seen introductory
lectures period so i highly recommend
people
find you on youtube and watch it if
you're curious at all about viruses it
it um
yeah there's a lot of times throughout
watching it
i felt like whoa
yeah that's my goal is to and that's
what my students tell me one student
once said i every day after every
lecture i could go home and tell my
roommate something she didn't know
yeah and and blew her away so the number
of viruses is really an amazing number
so that number 10 to the 31 is actually
just the bacterial viruses in the ocean
so there are viruses that infect
everything on the planet including
bacteria there are a lot of bacteria in
the ocean and so 10 to the 31 is from
basically particle counts of seawater
all over the world so there are more
viruses than 10 to the 31 but just in
the ocean
and that number is so big
first of all the mass exceeds
that of elephants on the planet by a
thousand fold
and if you lined up those viruses end to
end they would go
200 million light years
into space it's so big a number
it's it's amazing and then yes 10 to the
20 some
infections per second of these viruses
killing bacteria and releasing all this
organic matter and that's part of this
what we call the biogeochemical pump
cycling of material in the ocean
the bacteria die
they start to sink and then they get
metabolized and converted to compounds
that that are needed a lot of it gets
released as carbon dioxide and so forth
so these are actually really important
cycles that are catalyzed by the virus
well it's so wild that nature has
developed a mechanism for mass murder
about bacteria that's one way to look at
it but it's just what happened right
it's interesting i mean um i wonder what
the evolutionary advantage of like such
fast cycling of life
is
is it just an accident of evolution that
viruses are so numerous
or is it um
is it uh is it a feature not a bug
so the the fast is
it rain it does not all fast not all
viruses are fast some are 20 minutes per
cycle some take
weeks per cycle
um
but that's just per second there's so
many viruses in the ocean that that's
what you get per second no matter how
fast the cycle is but
i look at it this way viruses were
probably the first
organic entities to evolve on the planet
long ago billions billion years ago
just as the earth cooled an organic
molecules began to form
i think these self
we call them self replicators
they're just short things that today
would look like rna which is the basis
of
many viruses right
they evolved and they were able to
replicate of course they were just naked
molecules they had no protection and it
was just rna-based
and that that's tough because rna is
pretty fragile in the in the world and
it probably didn't get very big as a
consequence
but then
proteins evolved and i'm skipping like
hundreds of millions of years of
evolution proteins evolved maybe without
a cell
maybe with the cell
but then
to make a cell there probably were some
rna-based cells early on but they were
pretty simple but the cells that we know
of today even bacteria and single-celled
eukaryotes
they have very long dna genomes and you
need a lot of dna to make a complicated
cell and so we think at some point
the rna
became dna
and probably one of the earliest enzymes
that arose
is the enzyme that could copy that rna
into dna which we now know today as
reverse transcriptase which my former
boss david baltimore and howard tement
co-discovered
and that that enzyme arose and copied
rna to dna and then you could build big
cells with because dna can be millions
and millions of bases in length and rna
the longest rna we know of is
40 000 bases not much bigger than the
source cov2
you